[Music]
good morning isn't it
Jean Helen Hunt oh my god it's you I
thought for a second and I almost said
something the you are Helen Hunt you did
say so
oh I should have gotten this whole
chance encounter on video can you go
back and say hashtag line what are you
doing here I go here
what's up I know like one time you go
here yeah I'm like a student like oh
here like this books books books books
are you telling me that your dad got you
into the college that I'm like I need
Kent Russell to get me in love get your
helm of this okay that could be a
different dad if your dad thinks that
I'm just gonna take care of you he is
sorely mistaken sure that's we're
talking about my dad ran out here okay
well she might just a cake beef walking
up hey excuse me do you guys know where
the philosophy building is well I think
the gym that way no I was asking about
the philosophy building I'm a mid
semester transfer today's my first day
me too
absolutely um yeah I'd love to work out
later maybe yeah oh my gosh she's into
me
oh whoa whoa whoa what is the sorority
rush this is college joke okay Jean the
last time I saw you you tried to get me
the death penalty Billy that was a
courtroom gag between old pals wait wait
okay okay look the judge made me decide
between getting a job or going back to
school so now I'm trying to school Wayne
why go to one of you I do things I want
on your resume or your mumbling so where
should I enroll your bag College joke
we're doing what this is my name's your
clothes
that's my winter clothes you make fun of
me that's what catch me up you're my
brow
case of the TV that's why you don't see
fun but they still wanna be